and there you go
um
i'm told we have breaking news uh
it would appear that uh a certain world
champion magnus carlson
has decided to
not play
today's game
and
oh my goodness
the clock is going to be started there's
a 10 minute rule that if you don't show
up by 10 minutes you're
forfeited
and
yeah i i i'm sitting here i'm here
sitting here going to play in a bit of a
kind of a stand silence i don't really
know how to react to this i'm
you know there will be some developments
i assume but for for now yeah this is
obviously not not great but uh
not much we can say until
the the the team of magnus explain what
uh is going on in the world champion's
uh mine is the last 10 minutes to show
up so 10 minutes for him to change his
mind exactly but that is the news that
we are getting of course we still don't
have the full information on the
reasoning and things like that but we'll
get it to you guys as soon as possible
uh a stunning development i'm sure but i
do i do know that uh david sedgwick the
tournament or international arbiter has
called for increased uh security
measures as we see
shakriar
uh sitting down yeah it's so it's very
much unfun and fun for shock you kind of
feel for shah who had to prepare for
this game and uh you know any game
against his any game against the world
champion is is you know going to be an
important game in the tournament and
i think in particular treasures
chances to play against the best of the
world he was on our on our couch here so
to speak explaining how much he still
loves chess and how much it is important
for him to play to play interesting
chess uh so for him there you know
sitting and you know probably coming to
the realization that the game might not
actually start on his board so one it's
not that great with very very stunning
developments everybody i think
you're hearing
the arbors are announcing the withdrawal
of uh magnus uh for well the forfeit i
want to say will will determine the
withdrawal later and there's his
opponent
shakriar saying my gosh i came to play
the world chess champion
and he's not here yeah uh
today is um
you have to assume this this day will
sort of reverberate
for for for a bit because you don't you
don't see this very often and uh yeah
absolutely
whatever the reasons are it will it will
be a very very big talking point uh
going forward but for now we
all all the information we have is what
you're seeing on your screen right now
this game is not a game today exactly
magnus will have 10 minutes to show up
it's unlikely he's and we expect that he
will forfeit
his game
um
uh stunning uh what can you say
i can't even remember the last time
something like this has happened
in a tournament of this caliber help me
out guys with some
some chess history
yeah i i don't know i'm
we could have done some research if we
knew but
right
oh my goodness oh my goodness um
okay
well
i mean in the absence of uh
magnus may i suggest we turn our
attention to the moves that have been
played in the games and